plus 7,1 pour cent de chômeurs en france
en mars
c'est une hausse record en un mois selon
le ministère du travail
et d'après les experts ce n'est que le
début un scénario qui rappelle celui de
au début de la crise financière il est
certain que la crise aura des
conséquences sur le chômage dans les
mois qui viennent amorcée aux etats-unis
la crise des subprimes n'épargne pas
l'europe la france l'a prend de plein
fouet et entre en récession dès
l'automne 2008 une récession
je veux dire destruction de richesse
donc ça se traduit par bien sûr moins
d'investissements ça se traduit
automatiquement du coup par des
destructions d'emplois et bien sûr par
une augmentation du chômage
cet expert avait vu juste entre 2008 et
2011 le taux de chômage en france outre
mer compris à l'exception de mayotte
passait de 7,7 pour cent à 9,4 pour cent
soit 496 mille chômeurs de plus en 2012
la barre des 10% été franchi et en 2014
le taux de chômage en france
atteignaient 10,4 pour cent parmi les
groupes les plus touchés les jeunes les
immigrés et les personnes peu qualifiées
en 2012
cet homme faisait face à cette réalité
je fais beaucoup d'entretien et à
l'arrivée la réponse est toujours la
même le terme très employé aujourd'hui
c'est vous êtes pro junior autre
conclusion de l'insee l'accroissement du
nombre de chômeurs longue durée
ceux à la recherche d'un emploi depuis
au moins un an
entre 2008 et 2014 il passait de 758 nil
à 1,3 million cet ancien cadre par
exemple cherchent est un emploi depuis
19 mois
on finit par se poser la question
pourquoi ça dure pourquoi j'arrive pas à
trouver qu est ce que je devrais faire
en plus et c'est très angoissant
face à cette situation exceptionnelle le
président nicolas sarkozy créé un
nouveau ministère pour mener son plan de
relance à sa tête patrick devedjian pour
faire face à l'accroissement du chômage
voici l'une des mesures envisagées par
le chef de l'état c'est une mesure forte
au service des très petites entreprises
chacune de celles qui engageront un
nouveau salarié en 2009 ne payeront
aucune charge sociale sur ce nouvel
emploi créé ces 700 millions d'euros de
plus en france ce n'est qu'à partir de
fin 2014 soit six ans après le début de
la crise que le taux de chômage va
progressivement diminuer au dernier
trimestre 2010 9
il s'établissait à 8,1 pour cent son
niveau le plus bas depuis 2008 le
gouvernement envisageait un taux à 7 %
en 2022
un scénario compromis en ces temps de
crise sanitaire
[Musique]